Silicon Valley is it a meritocracy well
it's more matter product than any other
industry in America I worked in law and
politics professionally and as a result
of representing other industries and as
a lawyer certainly had exposure to the
financial services industry a lot of our
clients aviation industry it's a lot of
my clients by far more meritocratic and
the the definition of meritocratic would
be can you go from like literally
nowhere to success overnight and the
answer is absolutely yes I mean one of
the most interesting things about
Silicon Valley is you meet people very
early in their career sometimes and you
know you wake up a couple years later
and they're more successful than you a
magnitude more oh yeah I mean I have
former interns of mine that are like
super successful and you know there's a
crush or soul or does it inspire you
no it's very inspiring it's inspiring a
couple dimensions it actually makes me
more ambitious and and intelligence me
to be better at my own job and
performance be you know it gives me
energy to help people earlier in their
career like if I can teach or mentor a
couple things that allows them to
accelerate their own learnings you can
see the benefit of that where they they
go further and faster yeah it's
interesting to me as well because it
seems like this is the most helpful
industry I've ever met as well there's
like this really I mean beautiful
tradition here of helping people who are
new to the industry and it it also makes
me wonder why the industry's kind of got
this rap of like not being a meritocracy
being an old boys club and like that you
you have to know somebody to make it
here it's like we didn't know anybody at
PayPal I keep putting this out we were a
bunch of misfits that had no previous oh
were you ever oh yeah I know your
friends yeah good friend David Peter or
whatever backs everybody yeah everybody
misfit and you know even the media
picked up on that there was like cover
stories and magazines about earth to
PayPal because we're that different yeah
and we made our own network and we made
our own success and then we've rebuilt a
network ourselves but we didn't have any
connections and then you know I've seen
like ridiculous books written that's
oh well we went to some of us went to
Stanford actually truthfully less than
half the company went to Stanford most
went to University of Illinois which is
a large state school in the middle of
America that's where all the engineers
came from none of them came from
Stanford secondly you know and there's
40,000 I think graduates or 40,000
students at the University in Illinois
and any given time only one of them was
max right you know so like the idea that
that was some advantage or Stanford you
know there's 6,000 undergrads at a time
yeah Peter created PayPal yeah not the
other 5999 so the idea that like
Stanford some major advantage is just
ridiculous with the math being one to
five five thousand nine hundred ninety
nine yeah
so I think people make their own sort of
success in Silicon Valley welcomes out I
mean you look at the immigrant status
there's all these different ways to cut
the data but at the end of the day
almost every important
Silicon Valley company the last 50 years
had at least one founder that was a
first-generation immigrant law and Steve
Jobs oh yeah its ax
I mean the entire everybody immigrated
from India I mean like yeah you have a
bunch of refugees from communist
countries you know we had to start the
PayPal stat of you know half the
founders of PayPal built bombs in high
school oh boy yeah they did but you have
to remember like mostly we're building
bombs in communist countries which is
probably a reasonable thing to be doing
freedom fighters not terrorists exactly